now the draft opinion which we proposed  yesterday and which will be published  soon and sets out a number of measures  which we would like to see member states  putting in place these include measures  on personal hygiene and health measures  for travelers including recommended mask  wearing on flights from China it will  also include things such as waste more  Wastewater monitoring for aircrafts  genomic surveillance airports and  increased monitoring and sequencing  increased EU vigilance on testing and  vaccination that's about ensuring we  have our own immunity levels as high as  they can be and then we also propose a  discussion on the need for pre-testing  of passengers from China prior to  departure and this is something which we  saw the overwhelming majority of  countries are in favor of bit Blick of  Corvette  um  foreign